hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
I'll be discussing the order flow that
took place after the uh
um you know Powell's talk at uh Jackson
Hole and before we jump in again
remember
um if you enjoy learning from these
videos and want to see more be sure to
hit the Subscribe button and
you know be sure to leave a comment for
me in the comments section you know with
your biggest takeaway I love hearing
your feedback even if you have a
suggestion for another video be sure to
put that in there and
again you know your support really goes
a long way in helping me want to create
more awesome videos just like this so if
you're getting value from my channel
want to see more be sure to hit the
Subscribe button and let's go uh jump
into today's topic okay so again you
know today was uh Jackson Hole meeting
and Powell uh said some comments that
basically uh signaled that the FED is
going to intend to keep raising rates
this year and you know honestly everyone
was sort of waiting to see what Powell
had to say that's why we had been in
sort of quiet uh Market mode uh until
you know he would say what he's going to
say right and you can see we're
basically a little sideways action you
know since the cash open basically we
had hit that new high of ten and a half
or trading basically between 10 and uh
double low
or oh one
um then he starts talking yappen Market
Spike stop comes off a bit then goes up
makes new highs then we sell off from
our highs all the way down to lows new
lows new lows um and then we get a nice
little bounce up from the lows at 65 and
a quarter all the way back up into the
80s and it was a pretty quick move that
happened in about 10 minutes okay and
sort of what I want to talk about is you
know some of the interesting order flow
because you know a question had come up
about uh understood what is passive
Traders some um you know people that are
newer to order flow don't understand the
difference between passive Traders and
aggressive Traders because when you have
um you know a buying and balance that is
aggressive buying if you have a solid
imbalance that is aggressive selling but
who are they selling to or who are they
buying from they're buying from the
passive Traders and the easiest way to
explain it right is if you look on a
trading dome right we're all familiar
with the Dome
all right you see the current bid
offer right it's a two-way auction all
the volume you see sitting on the bid
that is your resting liquidity that is
your passive buyers people that are
happy to buy it here at 17 and three
quarters 17 and a half 17 and a quarter
17. just as you have passive sellers up
here on the offer side people that are
working an offer at 18 and a half at six
uh 18 and three quarters right 57
offered at 19. you know and so on these
are your passive buyers these are your
passive sellers for a trade to happen
someone has to cross that bid offer line
right someone has to you know either buy
at the market or sell at the market or
if you're working a bid you have to move
your bid up from whatever price you know
if you're at say you're down here at 44
18 you just want to get filled you lift
it up and you buy the current offer at
19 and a half just as if you're trying
to sell it up here at 23 you know but
we're trading 20 and a half and you're
like losing patience you just want to
get out of this trade you know because
you you had bought earlier you're trying
to sell it there at 23. what you're
going to do is you're going to become a
aggressive seller you're going to move
it down from 23 just ah just get me out
you know you're gonna need to sell at
the market and hit the bid or you're
going to move your offer price down from
23 down to 20 and a half you're going to
cross that bid offer line because again
if you move it down to 20 and three
quarters you'll be a passive seller
you'll be sitting on the offer you'll be
behind whatever number of contracts is
in front of you you may get filled you
may not get filled okay basically
passive buyers passive sellers are
traders that are willing to let the
market come to them right they're
they're happy to
um provide liquidity to the market but
at the same time they may not get filled
okay
so just you know that that's really the
difference between someone that's
passive someone that's aggressive
aggressive Traders want to get filled
they will pay the market price or sell
at the market price passive buyers want
to buy it there predetermined price
passive sellers want to sell at their
predetermined price it's a bit like
um you know buying a a car right you go
to the car dealer
there's a sticker price up there right
the new uh you know the new Chevy
Corvette whatever they sell for now I
don't know a hundred thousand dollars
but you're like man I ain't got a
hundred thousand I'll bid 85 000.
okay well you're not going to buy it
right because the dealers a passive
seller at a hundred thousand he's fine
because you'll know he'll get someone
come in pay him a hundred thousand
dollars for it all right so he doesn't
have to be aggressive now if you know if
you do have the money for it and you're
like oh I want this car you know I'm in
love with it I love the design the color
everything I want it you're going to pay
the offer you're going to be the
aggressive Trader in that sense you're
going to
go up and pay the offer you're going to
move your bid from 80 000 up to a
hundred thousand okay
and and we go through that you know in
our lives
um you know in grocery stores everything
is sort of a fixed price you know
whatever the price is on the Shelf but
if you go to like to a farmer's market
or something right you know I went to a
vegetable market today near our house um
you know a smart farm when they're
they're growing their own food and they
sell vegetables and you know sometimes
you could haggle like oh you know if
it's late in the day they don't want to
be carrying it back it might spoil so
they're going to lower the price right
they're going to be more aggressive
right because they got Supply if it's at
the end of the day you know they got
Supply that you know is going to go
around so they'll just keep lowering the
price until it's all gone
all right so that's that's a case of you
know an aggressive uh seller right
someone with Supply in the market now
today it was quite interesting because
after we hit this low
right we started around we got this nice
sharp rally right up to 88 okay and what
was appearing in the order book so
remember right we had been you know
trading um you know much higher sold off
trading down here at making this new low
here at what was that 79 and a half made
a new low here at uh 75 and three
quarters a new low 74 and a half uh 72
and a quarter 71 Etc down here till we
get this low at 65.
and then
with a sharp rally but
in the order flow and this is where
looking at the actual volumes that take
place now this is not something you see
all the time but when you see it you
really want to pay attention to it
because we're at the low of the day and
any
bullish signs in the order flow right
is something you want to pay attention
to and you know there were some nice
bullish signs in the order flow right we
got the aggressive buying coming in here
you guys see the stack buying imbalance
coming in here you see a bunch of zero
prints and as we start working our way
back up obviously we got the value area
but the most clear thing the most
obvious thing that came in off this low
is the strong buy-in coming in here at
70 and at 70 and a quarter because again
we had just been trading 70 for the last
one two three four five six seven eight
minutes you know this eight minutes ban
over the last 10 minutes we've been
trading there back and forth around that
area for about
eight eight of those 10 minutes and then
a big buyer came in here right and let's
just open up this chart a little bit
more you can see 1278 that's a strong
bid
917 that's a strong bid
right this is a one minute e-mini chart
and you know this is why I talk about
you know when you are trading a market
you know decide on the chart you're
going to look at get familiar with it
know it inside out so I know that
anything over a thousand at one price
level is big but what makes this more
important more special
is it's coming in in an area
as right after we made a low that we had
just been trading that so I know this is
fresh right I know this is not 1278 uh
contracts that trade you know as we're
going down arresting liquidity like this
951 to me this is resting liquidity it's
been order sitting in the book for you
know all session but we trade through
that go lower go lower go lower hit a
low Market starts ticking up all of a
sudden you got a big buyer coming into
the market now this big buyer you know
he could be buying some pretty
aggressively but the fact that he sat on
the bid to absorb whatever selling
pressure there is because we're down at
the low right that's where a lot of
people are going to sell is down at the
low and he's there absorbing all that
buying 1200 contracts even the one tick
above 900 contracts you know that's over
2 000 contracts just between 70 and 70
and a quarter
that's going to be a support level
right 70.
70 and a quarter then we you know next
Bar opens up you know one tick below it
goes a little bit lower goes back up I
see another big bid coming in here
25 22.
look at that 2 000 here another two and
a half thousand here
okay these
are bids that are coming in these are
fresh bids again these are not just
people dropping offers in the book you
know on the Market's trading 10 handles
away this is bids coming in right now in
the market that's the importance of it
right and I carry I put extra importance
on it when it's in an area that we've
just been trading because this is our
low of the day all of a sudden someone's
stepping up
I'm a buyer I'll buy whatever you want
to sell at this price
three ticks higher three points higher
the buyer is still there I'll buy
whatever you got in another up here
43.80 but again you know the one up here
is
again it's obvious you know 1100 99 in
1985 700 but down here this 25 22 sticks
out like a sore thumb this 1278 917
stick out like a sore thumb
you should have been
noticing this to get in in this bar
before the market puts in this bar that
goes from 76 all the way up to 84. right
and obviously you know once we got up
there right look at these support levels
all right I drew these lines here 73 and
a quarter 70. these are going to be my
support levels
right and the market doesn't even come
back anywhere near those levels how do I
know that this volume of 25 22 or this
1278 is strong volume well just by
looking at the volumes that's going
through earlier
you know like I said there was a 951
contracts here
um 600 500
these are double triple five times the
amount of volume going through at that
price so I know it's a strong level I
know it's an important level that I want
to focus on
now
just get back talking about volumes a
bit again the 1985 is also important but
really you know you want to have that
sign closer to the low of the day rather
than after you just rally 15 handles you
know I'd rather have see the sign coming
in here five handles off the low then 15
handles but again that's that's still
strong
um and then you know Market went up and
I just want to touch on this other
volume up here just to give you
something were to come in
so it was a strong offer in the market
but uh
where'd you go here there's 12 19 here
it is
I thought it came in on a red bar so
like this 12 19 here people say well you
know this 1219
that's coming in at 43.90 okay is that
important okay well
it's important right but it's it's
resting liquidity this is coming in here
right we haven't been trading there for
you know this is coming in at 10 28. we
haven't been there since you know 943
it's not like we were just trading here
right 43.90 trading up at this bar you
know trading back and forth and then see
this come in this is resting liquidity
and while it's important
you know I don't put it in as much
importance in it as I did in this 25-22
and even this other volume down here the
1278 because I know this is just fresh
buying coming in
you know this one you know people are
putting it in you know we could have
been trading in the 70s down here or
even lower in the 60s okay and we trade
it we get through it okay and sort of
the old concept of you know if I want to
treat this as
um resistance okay well we're above
resistance we're trading above
resistance close above that level next
bar trades down to that resistance level
and rejects it comes back up we're
trading higher okay so what do I gotta
be thinking now
resistance becomes support
and what happens
because what we're selling here right
unless they unless these guys were the
ones that bought it earlier down there
in that in that other volume that went
through the 2500 or or the 1200
you know if this is a fresh short
looking for someone looking forward to
sort of sell off
um it's not you know so they got us
probably scramble to try and cover it in
here some of these guys maybe try and
scratch it to break even that's how
previous resistance become support right
and then the market went um back up okay
so
you know and we're here got another big
volume 2670 but at this point right yeah
it's nice to see Heavy volume coming in
you know in a move up really the best
most of you know the best part that you
want to see it that's happening that you
want to see it is right off the low of
the day when an area that you've just
been trading
um right here right
right here right right off the low I
mean we're literally three bars third
bar off the low fourth bar off the low
after it's been made I mean those are
the trades that
um you know when you see them you got to
pay attention you guys you gotta put the
pieces together that's why I make these
videos again it's not something you see
um often but when you see that strong
bids coming in off of the low of the day
act on it take advantage of it okay so
that wraps up today's video on sort of
you know passive and by passive buyers
and sellers and aggressive buyers and
sellers sort of the importance of where
they're coming into the market so again
you know if you find these tips helpful
for your understanding of order flow let
me know right let me know what you'd
like me to discuss next by leaving a
comment below and again if you haven't
already subscribe to the channel be sure
to right so you don't miss any of my
um new videos that come out so thanks
for watching thanks for being a part of
this community your support is
appreciated I'll see you in the next
video